У Львові багато хто каже, що Київ
не дає їм самостійно розібратися зі своїм сміттям
і збудувати завод для переробки відходів.
А як це в Німеччині?
Німеччина - федеративна республіка. Тож, Берлін
як столиця країни не займається питаннями сміття в інших містах.
Крім того, столиця федеральної землі
теж не видає дозволи на будівництво заводів
на підпорядкованій їй території.
Ці питання вирішуються на рівні районів.
Приміром, мер Бонна хоче побудувати сміттєпереробний завод.
Він заручається підтримкою міської ради.
А потім затверджує проект в районному уряді в Кельні.
Тож, ані Берлін, ані столиця федеральної землі Дюссельдорф
не займаються сміттям Бонна.
Тут сміттєпереробний завод побудували понад 25 років тому.
Тоді це коштувало 300 мільйонів дойчемарок.
Причому майже половина цієї суми
пішла на систему очистки викидів із заводських труб.
Екологічні стандарти тут дуже високі.
Цей завод у Бонні щороку спалює 250 тисяч тонн сміття
і дає електроенергії майже на півмільярда мегават-годин на рік.
Працює тут лише 85 людей.
Нині ж, щоб звести сміттєпереробний завод,
потрібно в середньому від 40 до 100 мільйонів євро.
Отже, у Німеччині ані столиця країни, ані столиця федеральної землі
не переймається сміттєвими проблемами окремо взятого міста.
Це відповідальність самого міста
та району, до якого воно належить.
Щоб подібна модель запрацювала в Україні,
потрібна децентралізація і більше прав для місцевих громад.